>>> Priyanka Chopra Jonas made
more than 50 bollywood films.
When she decided to take on
projects in the U.S., it was not
an easy transition.
We continue our conversation
with the problem she faced as
she tried to make it big in
America.
In 2015, you come to this
country.
And you become the first south
Asian to star in an American
television series as an FBI
recruit in the TV show
"Quantico."
Here you are.
>> You stole classified
documents from a federal
building.
You planted surveillance
equipment in my office.
Do you have any idea how much
trouble you'd be in if I told
anyone?
>> Tell them.
Tell the entire world, for all I
care.
You're still lying to me.
You're still manipulating me.
When does it stop, Liam?
I am not scared of you anymore,
and I will do whatever it takes
to find out the truth about my
father.
>> You were a big star in India.
Why did you decide to make the
move to the U.S.?
>> Well, there were, you know --
everybody wants to grow and
evolve.
I was looking to kind of spread
my wings.
I wanted to have the opportunity
to do music for a hot second, I
quickly realized I'm a better
actor than a pop star.
I never thought about it in
India, circumstances brought me
here.
I kind of always sort of -- I
worked for about ten years to
get to a point where I was a
leading lady, and I wanted to be
able to look for mainstream
spots in entertainment here.
There were very few people like
me that did that at that time.
To be able to get that job after
working towards it, you know --
this was not written for an
Indian woman.
I just went in, auditioned like
everybody else, and got the job.
Was really validating.
>> So you talk briefly about you
were going to be a pop star.
We even explored that.
>> Oh, come on.
Stop it, Chris.
>> It's not so bad, priyanka.
>> Okay.
>> So you had a song that for a
while was the opening song on
NFL network Thursday night
football.
Here you are.
♪♪
♪ I know you've got your own
town I know you've got your own
ways ♪
♪ I know there's a place like
home but I know you're gonna
like it ♪
>> I was so young.
>> Is that what you do, look
back at her --
>> That was 10 years ago or
something, I was 30 or
something, that's crazy.
>> I heard the reaction in
social media was not -- I mean,
yes there were obviously people
who liked it, but also a lot of
racism.
>> Well, yeah.
NFL, NFL network got a lot of
the tweets and stuff.
Or things saying, who's she?
Who's this person?
Why should she be on American
TV?
Football, it should be an
American person.
It was very confusing because I
was just an artist with a song
that they liked.
But props to NFL, they doubled
down for next year.
>> Was that hurtful to you, or
by that point had you sort of
been through that and it didn't
hit you?
>> No, it hits you every time.
It hits you.
All of it hits you.
Criticism.
The fact that my job requires me
to be dissected, and you know,
microscopically -- everything I
say, my home, my family,
everything is looked at.
But that's the nature of the
beast, and I've done it for 23
years now.
I'm not expecting its nature to
change.
You've got to start protecting
yourself, and I started doing
that many years ago.
Yes, of course it was hurtful.
But I'm someone who does wear
blinders.
I'm not -- and I believe in, you
know, letting my work speak for
itself.
And the best shutdown to people
like that who said that I didn't
belong is to belong.
Today I have, you know, the
number one series in the world
on the show, and I'm sitting
here talking to Chris Wallace.
>> Man, it doesn't get better
than that.
>> So who won?
Who won?
>> One of the things that
changed as you grew and got more
success, I heard that when you
started, you felt you had to
shed your ethnicity to get jobs,
to get accepted here in the U.S.
But that as you've grown and
become priyanka Chopra Jonas,
that you are -- now you embrace
your ethnicity on screen?
>> When I first started working
here, I think that -- I did not
want to be the checking the box.
Normalizing my culture has been
a long walk.
And there are few of us that are
doing it, and culture should be
normalized because children
should be exposed to different
kinds of culture.
Culture's the best teacher in
the world.
Traveling around the world,
meeting -- different foods,
different forms, languages.
I think that became my quest for
a very long time.
I'm doing a lot of work where I
want to bring stories that are
about my culture and my people
and should be out there.
>> Well, speaking of your
culture, one way you embraced it
was your wedding to pop singer
Nick Jonas with this big
extravaganza in jodhpur.
Why did you want it to be so
big?
>> Because I never said I would
settle.
Everything I do is big.
I'm a bold person.
It was big in scale, but it was
it was the closest people to me
and my husband, and we kept it
very intimate, but I wanted to
get my head in a palace with a
75-foot train.
Why not?
>> And you could.
>> And I did.
>> All right.
Then last year, you and Nick had
your baby girl who was born
dangerously premature.
How big was she when she was
born?
>> Very small.
She was very, very small.
It was very touch and go for
about her whole third trimester.
She was in the NICU, and it was
many, many scary moments, but my
husband and I had each other,
and we had to be really tough in
that situation because she
needed that.
And here she is, happy as a
clam, smileyest Bailey no.
>> So she had to spend 100 days
in icu, and as I understand it
when she came home and you
didn't have all the monitors and
nurses that all the time you
would be putting your ear to her
heart --
>> Or my finger in front of her
knows to make sure she was
breathing.
Because I was a NICU mom.
The monitor didn't know what she
was feeling.
She couldn't try or communicate
in any way.
She had so many tubes in her,
you could hardly see her face.
It was very terrifying, but we
had so much support from our
family.
My mom, my husband's parents
came down and helped us, helped
her be surrounded by love and
feel cherished.
She's the happiest little thing.
>> How's she doing now?
>> She's great.
She's almost walking.
We're just about there now.
>> Finally, hold up your
right -- because I kept noticing
this.
Tell me about that and the story
behind it.
>> Well, it says daddy's little
girl, and it's my dad's hand
writing.
I lost my dad to cancer in 2013,
and he was my greatest champion,
biggest fan, like gregarious
laugh, loudest in the room, just
confident guy, and there was a
lot of silence after I lost my
dad in my life.
But he would never let me get a
tattoo, so I thought if I